to the first and only vice presidential
debate
of 2020 sponsored by the nonpartisan
commission
on presidential debates i'm susan page
of usa today
it is my honor to moderate this debate
an
important part of our democracy in
kingsbury hall tonight we have a small
and socially distant audience and we've
taken extra precautions during this
pandemic
among other things everyone in the
audience is required to wear a face mask
and the candidates will be seated 12
feet apart
the audience is enthusiastic about their
candidates but they've agreed to express
that enthusiasm
only twice at the end of the debate and
now
when i introduce the candidates please
welcome california senator kamala harris
and vice president mike pence
thank you
senator harris and vice president pence
thank you for being here
we're meeting as president trump and the
first lady continue to undergo treatment
in washington
after testing positive for covet 19. we
send our thoughts and prayers to them
for their rapid and complete recovery
and for the recovery of everyone
afflicted by the coronavirus
the two campaigns in the commission on
presidential debates have agreed to the
ground rules for tonight
i'm here to enforce them on behalf of
the millions of americans who are
watching
one note no one in either campaign or at
the commission
or anywhere else has been told in
advance what topics i'll raise
or what questions i'll ask this
90-minute debate will be divided into
nine
segments of about 10 minutes each i'll
begin a segment by posing a question
to each of you sometimes the same
question sometimes a different question
on the same topic you will then have two
minutes to answer
without interruption by me or the other
candidate
then we'll take six minutes or so to
discuss the issue
at that point although there will always
be more to say
we'll move on to the next topic we want
a debate that is lively but americans
also deserve a discussion that is civil
these are tumultuous times but we can
and will
have a respectful exchange about the big
issues
facing our nation let's begin with the
ongoing pandemic
that has cost our country so much
senator harris the coronavirus is not
under control
over the past week johns hopkins reports
that
39 states have had more coveted cases
over the past seven days
than in the week before nine states have
set new records
even if a vaccine is released soon the
next administration will face
hard choices what would a biden
administration do in january and
february
that a trump administration wouldn't do
would you impose
new lockdowns for businesses in schools
and hot spots
a federal mandate to wear masks you have
two minutes to respond without
interruption
thank you susan well the
american people have witnessed what is
the greatest
failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts 210
000 dead people in our country in just
the last several months
over seven million people who have
contracted this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne
that it will affect young people and
that
it would be contracted because it is
airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you can you imagine if you knew on
january 28th
as opposed to march 13th what they knew
what you might have done to prepare
they knew and they covered it up the
president said it was a hoax
they minimized the seriousness of it the
president said
you're on one side of his ledger if you
wear a mask you're on the other side of
his ledger
if you don't and in spite of all of that
today they still don't have a plan
they still don't have a plan well joe
biden does and our plan is about
what we need to do around a national
strategy for contact tracing for testing
for administration of the vaccine and
making sure that it will be free for all
that is the plan that joe biden has and
that i have
knowing that we have to get a hold of
what has been going on and we need to
save
our country and joe biden is the best
leader to do that and frankly this
administration has forfeited
thank you their right to re-election
based on this thank you senator harris
vice president pence more than 210 000
americans have died of covet 19
since february the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
is higher than that of almost every
other wealthy nation
on earth for instance our death rate is
two and a half times that of canada next
door
you head the administration's
coronavirus task force
why is the u.s death toll as a
percentage of our population
higher than that of almost every other
wealthy country
and you have two minutes to respond
without interruption susan thank you
and i want to thank the commission and
the university of utah for
hosting this event and uh senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
president donald trump did what no other
american president had ever done
and that was he suspended all travel
from china the second largest economy
in the world now senator
joe biden biden opposed that decision
he said it was xenophobic and hysterical
but i can tell you having led the white
house coronavirus task force that that
decision alone by president trump
bought us invaluable time to stand up
the greatest national mobilization
since world war ii and i believe it
saved hundreds of
thousands of american lives because with
that time we were able to reinvent
testing more than 115 million tests had
been done to date
we were able to see to the delivery of
billions of supplies so our doctors and
nurses had the resources support they
needed
and we began really before the month of
february was art to develop a vaccine
and to develop medicines and
therapeutics had been saving lives all
along the way
and under president trump's leadership
operation warp speed we believe we'll
have
literally tens of millions of doses of a
vaccine before the end of this year
the reality is when you look at the
biden plan it reads an awful lot
like what president trump and i and our
task force have been doing every step
of the way and quite frankly
when i look at their plan that talks
about advancing testing
creating new ppe developing a vaccine
it looks a little bit like plagiarism
which is something joe biden knows a
little bit about
i think the american people know that
this is a president who has put the
health of america first and the american
people i believe with my heart
can be proud of the sacrifices they have
made
it's safe thank you american lives
senator harris
would you like to respond absolutely
whatever the vice president
is claiming the administration has done
clearly it hasn't worked
when you're looking at over two hundred
and ten thousand dead bodies in our
country
american lives that have been lost
families that are grieving
that loss and you know the
vice president is the head of the task
force
and knew on january 28th how serious
this was and then
thanks to bob woodward we learned
that they knew about it and then when
that was exposed
the vice president said when asked well
why didn't you all tell anybody
he said because the president wanted
people to remain
calm well let's go i don't know but
susan
and then we'll give the vice president
so i want to ask the american people
how calm were you when you were panicked
about where you're going to get your
next roll of toilet paper
how come were you when your kids were
sent home from school and you didn't
know when they could go back
how kind thank you thank you when your
children couldn't see your parents
because you were afraid they could kill
them let's give vice president pence a
chance to respond vice presidents you
have one minute to receive you know
there's not a day gone by that i haven't
thought of every american family that's
lost a loved one
and i want all of you to know that
you'll always be in our hearts
and in our prayers but when you say what
the american people have done over
these last eight months hasn't worked
that's a great disservice
to the sacrifices the american people
have made
the reality if i may if i may finish
that
the reality is dr fauci said everything
that he told the president in the oval
office the president told the american
people
now president trump i will tell you has
boundless confidence in the american
people and he always spoke with
confidence that we'd get through this
together
but when you say it hasn't worked when
dr fauci and dr burks and our medical
experts came to us in the second week of
march
they said if the president didn't take
the unprecedented step
of shutting down roughly half of the
american economy
that we could lose 2.2 million
americans and that's the reality thank
you they also said to us if we did
everything right susan we could still
lose more than 200 000 americans
vice president one life lost is too many
susan
but the american people i believe
deserve credit
for the sacrifices that they have made
putting the health of their family
and their neighbors first our doctors
our nurses our first thank you vice
president pence and i'm going to speak
up on behalf of what the american people
have done vice president pence you were
in the front row in a rose garden event
11 days ago
what seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now a
cluster of coronavirus cases among those
who were there
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's safety guidelines
to protect themselves from covet
when you at the white house have not
been doing so
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts
they're willing to put the health of
their families and their neighbors and
people they don't even know
first president trump and i have great
confidence in
in the american people and and their
ability
to take that information and put it into
practice
in the height of the epidemic when we
were losing
a heartbreaking number of 2500 americans
a day
we surged resources to new jersey and
new york and new orleans and detroit we
told the american people what needed to
be done and the american people made the
sacrifices
when the outbreak in the sun belt
happened this summer again americans
stepped forward
but the reality is the work of the
president of the united states goes on
a vacancy on the supreme court of the
united states
uh has come upon us and the president
introduced judge amy coney barry
thank you thank you vice president if i
may say that rose garden event
then a great deal of speculation about
it my wife karen and i were there and
honored to be there
many of the people who were at that
event susan actually were tested for
coronavirus
and it was an outdoor event which all of
our scientists regularly and routinely
advise
the difference here is president trump
and i trust the american people
to make choices in the best interest of
their health
joe biden and kamala harris consistently
talk about
mandates and not not just mandates with
the coronavirus but
a government takeover of health thank
you thank you green new deal
all government control we're about
freedom and respecting the freedom of
the american people
let's talk about respecting the american
people you respect the american people
when you tell them the truth
you respect the american people when you
have the courage to be a leader
speaking of those things that you may
not want people to hear but they need to
hear so they can protect themselves
but this administration stood on
information that if you had as a parent
if you had as a worker knowing you
didn't have enough money saved up
and now you're standing in a food line
because of the ineptitude
of an administration that was unwilling
to speak the truth to the american
people
so let's talk about caring about the
american people the american people have
had to sacrifice far too much
because of the incompetence of this
administration it is asking too much of
the people is
that they would not be equipped with the
information they need
to help themselves to protect their
parents president and they're i'm sorry
uh senator harris i mean i'm sorry
that's fine i'm comma no no you're
senator harris to me
um for life to get back to normal dr
anthony fauci and other experts say
that most of the people who can be
vaccinated need to be vaccinated
but half of americans now say they
wouldn't take a vaccine if it was
released now
if the trump administration approves a
vaccine before or after the election
should americans take it and would you
take it
if the public health professionals if dr
fauci if the doctors tell us that we
should take it i'll be the first in line
to take it absolutely but if donald
trump tells us i should
that we should take it i'm not taking it
vice president pence there have been a
lot of repercussions
from this pandemic in recent days the
president's diagnosis of covert 19 has
underscored the importance
of the job that you hold and that you
are seeking
that's our second topic tonight it's the
role of the vice president
one of you will make history on january
20th it will be the vice president
to the oldest president the united
states has ever had
donald trump will be 74 years old on
inauguration day
joe biden will be 78 years old that
already has raised concerns among some
voters
concerns that have been sharpened by
president trump's hospitalization in
recent days
vice president pence have you had a
conversation
or reached an agreement with president
trump about safeguards or procedures
when it comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
do you think you should you have two
minutes without interruption
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality is that we're going
to have a vaccine
senator in record time in unheard of
time in less than a year
we have five companies in phase three
clinical trials and we're right now
producing tens of millions of doses
so the fact that you continue to
undermine public confidence in a vaccine
if the vaccine emerges during the trump
administration i think is
is unconscionable and senator i i just
ask you
stop playing politics with people's
lives the reality
is that we will have a vaccine we
believe before the end of this year
and it will have the capacity to save
countless american lives and
and your continuous undermining
of confidence in a vaccine is just it
it's just
unacceptable and let me also say you
know the reality is when you talk about
about failure in this administration
we actually do know what failure looks
like in a pandemic
it was 2009 the swine flu arrived in the
united states
thankfully it was ended up not being as
lethal
as the coronavirus but before the end of
the year
when joe biden was vice president of the
united states
not seven and a half million people
contracted the swine flu
60 million americans contracted the
swine flu
if the swine flu had been as lethal as
the coronavirus in 2009
when joe biden was vice president we
would have lost 2 million
american lives his own chief of staff
ron klain
would say last year that it was pure
luck
that they did quote everything possible
wrong
and and we learned from that they left
the strategic national stockpile empty
they left uh an empty and hollow plan
but we still learn from it and i i think
the american
people i'm gonna say again can be vice
president pence i'm sorry we have done
and senator please thank you stop
undermining confidence in a vaccine
senator harris let me ask you the same
question that i asked vice president
pence which is
have you had a conversation or reached
an agreement with vice president biden
about safeguards or procedures when it
comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
and if you win the election next month
do you think you should you have two
minutes uninterrupted
so let me tell you first of all um the
day i got the call from
from joe biden it was actually a zoom
call
asking me to serve with him on this
ticket was probably one of the most
memorable day but memorable days of my
life
i you know i thought about my mother
who came to the united states at the age
of 19.
gave birth to me at the age of 25 at
kaiser hospital in oakland california
and the thought that i'd be sitting here
right now
i know would make her proud and she must
be looking down on this
you know joe and i were raised in a very
similar way
we were raised with values that are
about hard work
about the value and the dignity of
public service
and about the importance of fighting for
the dignity of all people and i think
joe
asked me to serve with him because you
know i have a career that included
being elected the first woman district
attorney of san francisco
where i created models of innovation for
for law enforcement in terms of reform
of the criminal justice system i was
elected
the first woman of color and black woman
to be elected attorney general of the
state of california where i ran
the second largest department of justice
in the united states second only to the
united states department of justice
and there i took on everything from
transnational criminal organizations
to the big banks that were taking
advantage of homeowners to for-profit
colleges that were
taking advantage of veterans and then of
course now i serve in the united states
senate is only the second black woman
ever elected
to the united states senate i serve on
the senate intelligence committee where
i've been in
regular receipt of classified
information about
threats to our nation and hot spots
around the world i've traveled the world
i've met
with our soldiers in our in war zones
and i think joe has asked me to serve
with him because he knows that we share
we share a purpose which is about
lifting up the american people
and after the four years that we have
seen of donald trump
unifying our country around our common
values
and principles thank you senator harris
you know neither neither
president trump nor vice president biden
has released a sort of detailed
health information that had become the
modern norm until the 2016 election
and in recent days president trump's
doctors have given misleading answers or
refused to answer basic questions about
his health
and my question to each of you in turn
is is this
information voters deserve
to know vice president pence would you
like to go first
well susan thank you and uh
and let me let me say on behalf of the
president
and the first lady how moved we've all
been
by the outpouring of prayers and concern
for the president and i do believe it's
emblematic of the prayers and
the concern that have ushered forth for
every american impacted
by the coronavirus but the care the
president received
at walter reed hospital the white house
doctors was exceptional
and the transparency that they practiced
all along the way will continue
the american people have a right to know
about the health and well-being
of their president and we'll continue to
do that
but i'm just extremely grateful and was
more than more than a little moved uh by
the broad and bipartisan support and
senator i want to thank you and joe
biden for your expressions genuine
concern
and i also want to congratulate you uh
as i did on that phone call
uh on the historic nature of your
nomination
i i never expected to be on this stage
four years ago so
i know the feeling but um the reality is
we've got an election before the
american people in the midst of this
challenging year
and the stakes have never been higher
because i think the choice has never
been i want to
give senator harris a chance to respond
to the same question i ask which is do
voters have a right to know
more detailed health information about
presidential candidates and especially
about presidents
especially when they're facing some kind
of challenge absolutely and that's why
joe biden has been
so incredibly transparent and certainly
by contrast
um the president has not um both in
terms of
health records but also let's look at
taxes
we now know because of great
investigative journalism
that donald trump paid 750 dollars in
taxes
when i first heard about it i literally
said you mean 750
000 and it was like no 750 dollars
we now know donald trump owes
and is in debt for 400 million dollars
and just
so everyone is clear when when we say in
debt it means you owe money to somebody
and it'd be really good to know who the
president of the united states the
commander-in-chief
owes money to because the american
people have a right to know
what is influencing the president's
decisions and is he making those
decisions on the best interest of the
american people of you
or self-interest so susan i'm glad you
asked about transparency
because it has to be across the board
joe has been incredibly transparent
over many many years the one thing we
all know about joe
he puts it all out there he he is
honest he is forthright but donald trump
on the other hand
has been about covering up everything
thanks thank you senator harris i want
to give you a chance to respond
vice president well look i i respect the
fact that joe biden spent 47 years in
public life
i respect your public service as well
thank you
the american people have a president was
a businessman
it's a job creator who's paid
tens of millions of dollars in taxes
payroll taxes property taxes he's
created tens of thousands of american
jobs
the president said those public reports
are not accurate
and the president's also released
literally stacks of financial
disclosures the american people can
review just as the law allows but the
distinction here is that
joe biden 47 years in public service
compared to president donald trump
who brought all of that experience four
years ago thank you very much
turned this economy around by cutting
taxes rolling back regulation
thank you thank you very much energy
fighting for free and fair trade
and all that thank you vice president if
joe biden and kamal harris you know
that's a good segue into our third
topic which is about the economy this
has been another aspect
of life for americans it's been so
affected
by this coronavirus we have a jobs
crisis
brewing on friday we learned that the
unemployment rate had declined to 7.9
percent in september
but the job growth had stalled and that
was before the latest round of layoffs
and furloughs
in the airline industry at disney and
elsewhere hundreds of thousands of
discouraged workers have stopped looking
for work
nearly 11 million jobs that existed at
the beginning of the year
haven't been replaced those hardest hit
include latinos
blacks and women senator harris the
biden harris
campaign has proposed new programs to
boost the economy and you would pay for
that
new spending by raising 4 trillion
dollars
in taxes on wealthy individuals and
corporations
some economists warn that could curb
entrepreneurial ventures
that fuel growth and create jobs would
raising taxes
put the recovery at risk and you have
two minutes to answer
uninterrupted thank you
on the issue of the economy i think
there couldn't be a more fundamental
difference
between donald trump and joe biden
joe biden believes you measured the
health and the strength of america's
economy
based on the health and the strength of
the american worker
and the american family on the other
hand you have donald trump
who measures the strength of the economy
based on how rich people are doing
which is why he passed a tax bill
benefiting the top one percent
and the biggest corporations of america
leading to
a two trillion dollar deficit that the
american people are going to have to pay
for
on day one joe biden will repeal that
tax bill
he'll get rid of it and what he'll do
with the money is invest it in the
american people
and through a plan that is about
investing in infrastructure something
that donald trump said he would do i
remember hearing about some
infrastructure week i don't think it
ever happened but joe biden will do that
he'll invest in infrastructure it's
about upgrading our roads and bridges
but also
investing in clean energy and renewable
energy joe is going to invest
that money in what we need to do around
innovation
there was a time when our country
believed in science
and invested in research and development
so that we were an
innovation leader on the globe joe biden
will use that money to invest in
education
so for example for folks who want to go
to a two-year community college it will
be free
if you come from a family that makes
less than a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars
you'll go to a public university for
free
and across the board will make sure that
if you have student loan debt it's cut
by ten thousand dollars
that's how joe biden thinks about the
economy which is it's about investing in
the people of our country
as opposed to passing a tax bill which
had the benefit
of letting american corporations go
offshore
to do their business thank you senator
harris
vice president pence your administration
has been predicting a rapid and robust
recovery but the latest economic report
suggests that's not happening
should americans be braced for an
economic comeback that is going to take
not months but a year
or more you have two minutes to answer
uninterrupted
when president trump and i took office
america had gone through the slowest
economic recovery since the great
depression
when joe biden was vice president they
tried to tax and spend and regulate and
bail our way back to a growing economy
president trump cut taxes across the
board
despite what senator harris says the
average american family of four had
two thousand dollars in savings in taxes
and
with the rise in wages that occurred
most predominantly for blue-collar
hard-working americans the average
household income for a family of four
increased by four thousand dollars
following president trump's tax cuts
but america you just heard senator
harris tell you on day one
joe biden's going to raise your taxes
it's really remarkable to things
i mean right after a time where we're
going through a pandemic that lost
22 million jobs at the height we've
already added back
11.6 million jobs because we had a
president who cut taxes rolled back
regulation
unleashed american energy fought for
free and fair trade
and secured four trillion dollars from
the congress of the united states
to give direct payments to families save
50 million jobs through the paycheck
protection program
we literally have spared no expense to
help the american people and the
american worker through this
joe biden and kamala harris want to
raise taxes
they want to bury our economy under a
two trillion dollar green new deal
which you were one of the original
co-sponsors of in the united states
senate
they want to abolish fossil fuels and
ban
fracking which would cost hundreds of
thousands of american jobs all across
the heartland
and joe biden wants to go back to the
economic surrender to china that when we
took office
half of our international trade deficit
was with china alone
and joe biden wants to repeal all of the
tariffs that president trump put into
effect to fight for american jobs and
american workers
joe biden says democracy's on the ballot
make no mistake about it susan
the the american economy the american
comeback is
on the ballot with four more years of
growth thank you
an opportunity four more years of
president donald trump
2021 thank you very much the biggest
economic year in the history of this
country thank you vice president pence
senator harris well i mean i that we saw
enough of it in last week's debate but i
think this is supposed to be a debate
based on fact and truth and the truth
and the fact is
joe biden has been very clear he will
not raise taxes on anybody who makes
less than four hundred thousand dollars
a year appeal the trump tax cut
mr vice president i'm speaking well i'm
speaking
be important if you said the truth joe
biden said twice in the debate last week
that he's going to repeal the trump tax
cuts
that was tax cuts that gave the average
working family
two thousand dollars in a tax break
every single year
senator that is absolutely not true that
is he only cutting
is he only going to repeal part of the
trump tax cuts if you don't mind letting
me finish
we can then have a conversation okay
please okay
joe biden will not raise taxes on anyone
who makes less than 400 thousand dollars
a year he has been very clear about that
joe biden will not end fracking he has
been very clear about that
joe biden is the one who
during the the great recession was
responsible
for the recovery act that brought
america back and now the
trump hence administration wants to take
credit
when they ran when they rode the court
coattails of joe biden's success
for the economy that they had at the
beginning of their term of course now
the economy is of complete disaster
but joe biden on the one hand did that
on the other hand you have donald trump
who has reigned over a recession
that is being compared to the great
depression on the one hand you have joe
biden
who was responsible with president
barack obama
for the affordable care act which
brought health care to over 20
million americans and protected people
with pre-existing conditions and what it
also did
is it saved to those families who
otherwise were going bankrupt
because of hospital bills they could not
afford on the other hand
you have donald trump who's in court
right now trying to get rid of
thank you trying to get rid of the
affordable care act
which means that you will lose
protections if you have pre-existing
conditions and i just this is very
important susan yes and it's about we
need to give
we need to get vice president i'd just
like to he interrupted me and i'd like
to just finish
please if you have a pre-existing
condition
heart disease diabetes breast cancer
they're coming for you
if you love someone who has a
pre-existing condition thank you
thank you coming for you if you are
under the age of 26 on your parents
coverage
they're coming for you senator harris
thank you let me give you a chance to
respond
well i hope we have a chance to talk
about health care because obamacare was
a disaster
the american people remember it well and
president trump and i have a plan
to improve health care and to protect
protect pre-existing
conditions for every american
but look senator harris you're you're
entitled to your own opinion but you're
not entitled to your own facts
you yourself said on multiple occasions
when you were running for president
that you would ban fracking joe biden
looked at a supporter in the eye
and pointed and said i guarantee i
guarantee
that we will abolish fossil fuels they
have a two trillion dollar version of
the green new deal susan that your
newspaper usa today said
really wasn't that very different from
the original green new deal
more taxes more regulation banning
fracking
abolishing fossil fuel crushing american
energy
and economics surrendered china is a
prescription for economic
decline president trump and i will keep
america growing
the v-shaped recovery that's underway
right now
will continue with four more years of
president donald trump thank you very
very much vice president pence once
again you've provided the perfect segue
to a new topic
which is climate change and vice
president pence i'd like to pose the
first question
to you this year we've seen
record-setting
hurricanes in the south another one
hurricane delta is now threatening the
gulf
and we have seen record-setting
wildfires in the west
do you believe as the scientific
community has concluded
that man-made climate change has made
wildfires bigger
hotter and more deadly and have made
hurricanes wetter
slower and more damaging you have two
minutes uninterrupted
thank you susan well first i'm very
proud of our record on the environment
and on conservation
according to all of the best estimates
are
our air and land are cleaner than any
time ever recorded
our water is among the cleanest in the
world and just a little while ago the
president signed the outdoors act as the
largest investment in our public
lands and public parks in 100 years
so president trump has made a commitment
to conservation into the environment
now with regard to climate change the
climate is changing
but the issue is what's the cause
and what do we do about it president
trump has made it clear that we're going
to continue to listen to the science
now joe biden and kamala harris would
put us back in the paris climate accord
they'd impose the green new deal
which would crush american energy would
increase the energy costs of american
families in their homes and literally
would crush
american jobs and president trump and i
believe that
the progress that we have made in a
cleaner environment
has been happening precisely because we
have a strong
free market economy you know what's
remarkable
is the united states has reduced co2
more than the countries that are still
in the paris climate accord but we've
done it through innovation
and we've done it through natural gas
and fracking
which senator the american people can go
look at the record i
i know joe biden says otherwise now as
you do
but the both of you repeatedly committed
to abolishing fossil fuel and banning
a fracking and so by creating the kind
of american innovation
we're actually steering toward a
stronger and better environment
with regard to wildfires president trump
and i believe that forest management has
to be front and center and even
governor gavin newsom from your state
has agreed we've got to work on forest
management
and with regard to hurricanes the
national
oceanic administration tells us that
actually is as difficult as they are
thank you vice president there are no
more hurricanes today than there were a
hundred years ago
thank you but many of the climate alarms
use hurricanes
and wildfires to try and sell these
goods of a green new deal
and president trump and i are going to
always put american jobs and american
workers
first senator harris as the vice
president mentioned you co-sponsored the
green new deal in congress
but vice president biden said in last
week's debate that he does not support
the green new deal but if you look at
the biden harris
campaign website it describes the
greener deal as a crucial framework
what exactly would be the stance of a
biden-harris administration
toward the green new deal you have two
minutes uninterrupted
sure so first of all i will repeat and
the american people know
that joe biden will not ban fracking
that is a fact
that is a fact i will
repeat that joe biden has been very
clear
that he thinks about growing jobs which
is why he will not increase taxes for
anyone who makes less than four hundred
thousand dollars
a year joe biden's economic plan
moody's which is a reputable wall street
firm
has said will create seven million more
jobs than
donald trump's and part of those jobs
that will be created by joe biden
are going to be about clean energy and
renewable energy
because you see joe understands that
the west coast of our country is burning
including my home state of california
joe sees what is happening on the gulf
states
which are being battered by storms joe
has seen and talked with
the farmers in iowa whose entire crops
have been destroyed because of floods
and so joe believes again in science
i'll tell you something susan i served
when i first got to the senate
on the committee that's responsible for
the environment do you know this
administration
took the word science off the website
and then took the phrase climate change
off the website
this we have seen a pattern with this
administration which is they don't
believe in science
and joe's plan is about saying we're
going to deal with it but we're also
going to create jobs
donald trump when asked about the
wildfires in california
and and the question was you know the
science is telling us this you know what
donald trump said
science doesn't know so
let's talk about who is prepared to lead
our country
over the course of the next four years
on what is an existential threat
to us as human beings joe is about
saying we're going to invest that in
renewable energy it's going to be about
the creation of millions of jobs
we will achieve net zero emissions by
2050
carbon neutral by 2035 joe has a plan
this has been a lot of talk from the
trump administration and really it has
been to go backward instead of forward
we will also re-enter the climate
agreement with pride
senator harris just said that climate
change is an existential threat
vice president pence do you believe that
climate change poses an existential
threat
as i said susan the climate is changing
we'll follow the science
but once again uh senator harris
uh is denying the fact that they're
going to raise taxes
on every american joe biden said twice
in the debate last week
that on day one he was going to repeal
the trump tax cuts
those tax cuts delivered two thousand
dollars in tax relief
to the average family of four across
america and with regard to banning
fracking i just recommend that people
look at the record you yourself said
repeatedly that you would ban fracking
you were the first
senate co-sponsor of the green new deal
and while joe biden denied the green new
deal susan thank you for pointing out
the green new deal is on their campaign
website and as usa today said
it's essentially the same plan as you
co-sponsored
with aoc when she submitted it in the
senate and you just heard the senator
say that she's going to resubmit
america to the paris climate accord look
the american people have always
cherished our environment we'll continue
to cherish it we've made great progress
reducing co2 emissions through american
innovation and the development of
natural gas through
fracking we don't need a massive 2
trillion dollar green new deal that
would impose all new mandates on
american businesses
and american families thank you joe
biden wants us to retrofit
4 million thank you vice president
business buildings
it makes no sense it will cost jobs
president trump
thank you very much america first he's
going to put jobs first and we're going
to take
care of our environment and follow the
sciences thank you so on the issue of
jobs senator
let's talk about that you the the vice
president earlier referred to
as part of what he thinks is an
accomplishment
um the the president's trade war with
china
you lost that trade war you lost it
what ended up happening is because of a
so-called trade war with china
america lost 300 000 manufacturing jobs
farmers have experienced bankruptcy
because of it we are in a manufacturing
recession
because of it and when we look at
where this administration has been there
are estimates that by the end of the
term
of this administration they will have
lost
more jobs than almost any other
presidential
administration and the american people
know what i'm talking about
you know i i think about 20 year olds
you know we have a 20 year old
20 something year old who are coming out
of high school in college right now and
you're wondering
is there going to be a job there for me
we're looking at people who are
trying to figure out how they're going
to pay rent by the end of the month
almost half of american renters
are worried about whether they're going
to be able to pay rent by the end of the
month
this is where the economy is in america
right now
and it is because of the catastrophe
and the failure of leadership of this
administration
thank you senator harris vice president
pence let me give you just 15 seconds to
respond because then i want to move on
to well
i i'd love to respond look uh lost the
trade war with china joe biden never
fought it
joe biden has been a cheerleader for
communist china through over the last
several decades
and and again senator harris you're
entitled to your opinion you're not
entitled to your own facts
when joe biden was vice president we
lost 200 000 manufacturing jobs
and president obama said they were never
coming back he said we needed a magic
wand to bring them back
in our first three years after we cut
taxes roll back regulation unleashed
american energy
this administration saw 500 000
manufacturing jobs created
and that's exactly the kind of growth
we're going to continue to see as we
bring our nation through thank you very
much pandemic
the green new deal your passive new
mandate your paris climate accord
it's going to kill jobs this time just
like it killed jobs
and i i just need to respond very much
15 seconds thank you
thank you joe biden
is responsible for saving america's auto
industry and you voted against it
so let's set the record straight thank
you
i'd like to talk about china we have as
our next
topic we have no more complicated or
consequential
foreign relationship than the one with
china it is
a huge market for american agricultural
goods it's a
potential partner in dealing with
climate change in north korea
and in a video tonight president trump
again blamed it
for the coronavirus saying china will
pay
vice president pence how would you
describe our
our fundamental relationship with china
competitors
adversaries enemies you have two minutes
thank you susan well let me before i
leave that let me let me speak to voting
records if i can
you know everybody knows that nafta cost
literally
thousands of american factories to close
we saw automotive jobs go south of the
border president trump
fought to renegotiate nafta and the
united states mexico canada agreement is
now the law of the land
american people deserve to know senator
kamala harris was one of only 10 members
of the senate to vote against the usmca
it was a huge win for american auto
workers it was a huge win for american
farmers especially dairy in the upper
midwest
but senator you you said it didn't go
far enough on climate change
that that you put your your radical
environmental agenda
ahead of american auto workers and ahead
of american
jobs and the american people deserve to
know that is probably why
newsweek magazine said that that kamala
harris was the most
liberal member of the united states
senate in 2019
more liberal than bernie sanders uh more
more liberal than
any of the others in the united states
senate so
now with regard to china look
susan first and foremost
china is to blame for the coronavirus
and president trump is not happy about
it he's made that very clear made it
clear again today
china and the world health organization
did not play straight with the american
people
they did not let our personnel into
china
to get information on the coronavirus
until the middle of february
fortunately president trump in dealing
with china from the outset of this
administration
standing up to china that had been
taking advantage of america for decades
in the wake of joe biden's cheerleading
for china
president trump made that decision
before the end of january to suspend
all travel from china and again the
american people deserve to know joe
biden opposed president trump's decision
to suspend all travel
from china he said it was hysterical he
said thank you vice president
of president trump china we're going to
continue to stand strong thank you vice
president
we want to improve the relationship but
we're going to level the playing field
and we're going to hold
china accountable for what they did to
america with the coronavirus thank you
senator harris let me ask you the same
question that i asked the vice president
how would you describe our fundamental
relationship with china are we
competitors
adversaries enemies you'll have two
minutes uninterrupted
susan the trump administration's
perspective and approach to china has
resulted in the loss
of american lives american
jobs and america's standing
there's a weird obsession that president
trump has had
with getting rid of whatever
accomplishment
was achieved by president obama and vice
president biden
for example they created within the
white house
an office that basically was responsible
for monitoring pandemics
they got away they got rid of it it's
not true there
was a team of disease experts
that president obama and vice president
biden
dispatched to china to monitor
what is now predictable and what might
happen they pulled them out
we now are looking at 210
000 americans who have lost their lives
let's look at the job situation we
mentioned before
the trade deal the trade war they wanted
to call it with china
it resulted in the loss of over 300
manufacturing jobs and a manufacturing
recession
and the american consumer paying
thousands of dollars more for goods
because of that failed war that they
called it
then let's talk about standing pew a
reputable
research firm has done an analysis
that shows that leaders of all of our
formerly allied countries have now
decided
that they hold in greater esteem and
respect
jinping the head of the chinese
communist party
then they do donald trump the president
of the united states the
commander-in-chief of the united states
this is where we are today because of a
failure of leadership by this
administration
senator harris we've seen changes in the
in the role of the united states in
terms of global leadership
over the past four years and of course
times do change
what's your definition we've seen
strains with china of course
as the vice president mentioned we've
seen strange with our traditional allies
in nato and elsewhere what is your
definition of the role of american
leadership
in 2020 so
you know joe is i love talking with joe
about a lot of these issues and you know
joe
he i think he said it quite well he says
you know foreign policy it might
sound complicated but really it's
relationships so just think about it as
relationships
and so we know this in our personal and
professional relationships
um you got to keep your word to your
friends
god be loyal to your friends people
who've stood with you got to stand with
them
you got to know who your adversaries are
and keep them in check
but what we have seen with donald trump
is that he has betrayed our friends
and it and and and and embraced
dictators around the world let's take
for example
russia so
russia i serve on the intelligence
committee of the united states senate
america's intelligence community told us
russia interfered in the election of the
president of the united states in 2016
and is playing in 2020.
christopher wray the director of the fbi
said the same
but donald trump the commander-in-chief
of the united states of america
prefers to take the word of vladimir
putin over the word of the american
intelligence community
you look at our friends at nato
he has walked away from agreements you
can talk look at the iran nuclear deal
which now has put us in a position
where we are less safe because they are
building up
what might end up being a significant
nuclear
arsenal we were in that deal guys we
were in the iran nuclear deal with
friends with allies around the country
and because of donald trump's unilateral
approach to foreign policy
coupled with his isolationism he pulled
us out and has made america less safe so
susan
it's about relationships and the thing
that has always been part of the
strength of our nation
in addition to our great military has
been that we keep our word but donald
trump doesn't understand that
because he doesn't understand what it
means to be honest
thank you thank you uh thank you senator
harris vice president
let me give you a chance to respond well
thank you um well president trump kept
his word when we moved the american
embassy to jerusalem
the capital of the state of israel when
joe biden was vice president they
promised to do that and they never did
we stood strong with our allies but
we've been demanding
nato is now contributing more to our
common defense than
ever before thanks to president trump's
leadership
we've strengthened our alliances across
the asia pacific
and we've stood strong against those who
would do us harm
you know when president trump came into
office isis had
captured an area of the middle east the
size
of pennsylvania but president trump
unleashed the american military and our
armed forces destroyed the isis
caliphate
and took down their leader al baghdadi
without one american casualty
al baghdadi was uh responsible
for the death of thousands um
but notably america's hearts today are
with the family of kayla mueller
your parents which are here with us
tonight in salt lake city
today two of the isis killers
responsible for kayla mueller's murder
were brought to justice in the united
states
jihadi john was killed on the
battlefield along with the other beetle
the reality is that when joe biden was
vice president we had an opportunity
to save kayla miller breaks my heart to
reflect on him but the military came
into the oval office
presented a plan they said they knew
where caleb was
baghdadi had held her for 18 months
abused her mercilessly before they
killed her but when joe biden was vice
president they hesitated
for a month and when armed forces
finally went in
it was clear she'd been moved two days
earlier and her family
says with a heart that broke the heart
of every american that
if president donald trump had been
president they believe kayla would be
alive today
thank you very much we destroyed the
isis caliphate
and you talk about re-entering the iran
nuclear deal i mean the last
administration transferred 1.8 billion
dollars
to the leading state sponsor thank you
very much of terrorism
president donald trump got us out of the
department thank you vice president and
and when casama solomonia was traveling
to baghdad thank you very much
to americans president donald trump
thank you vice president pence and
america
is is safer our allies are safer and the
american people know
president donald trump will never thank
you vice president take action
i would like to give senator harris a
chance to respond but not at such great
length because of course there are other
topics we want to talk about but i would
like equal time
yes thank you please go ahead first of
all to the mueller family
i i know about your daughter's case and
i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry um what happened to her
is awful and it should have never
happened
and i know joe feels the same way and i
know that president obama feels the same
way
um but you mentioned solemnani
let's let's start there so
after the strike on solemani there was a
counter
strike on our troops in iraq
and they suffered
serious brain injuries and do you know
what donald trump dismissed them as
headaches and this is about a pattern of
donald trump's
where he has referred to our
men who are serving in our military as
suckers and losers
donald trump who went to arlington
cemetery
and stood above the graves of our
fallen heroes and said
what's in it for them because of course
you know he only thinks about what's in
it for him let's take
what he said about john mccain a great
american hero
and and donald trump says he doesn't
deserve to be called a hero
because he was a prisoner of war
take and this is this is very important
when you want to talk about
who is the current commander-in-chief
and what they care about and what they
don't care about
public reporting that russia had
bounties on the heads
of american soldiers and you know what a
bounty is
it's somebody puts a price on your head
and they will pay it if you are
killed and donald trump had talked at
least six
times to vladimir putin and never
brought up the subject
joe biden would never do that thank you
joe biden would but joe biden
would hold russia to account for any
threat
to our nation's security or to our
troops
who are sacrificing their lives for the
sake of our democracy and our safety
thank you
senator harris this is such an important
issue but we have other important issues
as well
i want to i want to make sure we have a
chance i really have talked about that
clerk she has 15 seconds because well i
gotta
try to keep that look i'm sorry but vice
president you've had more time than
she's had
so far against president donald trump
regarding men and women of our armed
forces are absurd
i'm sorry my son is a captain in the
united states marine corps
my son-in-law is deployed in the united
states navy
i can assure all of you with sons and
daughters serving in our military
president donald trump not only respects
but reveres
all of those who serve in our armed
forces and any suggestion otherwise it's
ridiculous
thank you vice president american people
susan
american
agreed to the rules for tonight's debate
with the commission on presidential race
i'm here to enforce them which involves
moving from one topic to another
giving roughly equal time to both of you
which is what i'm trying very hard to go
right ahead so i want to go ahead
and move to the next topic which is an
important one
as the last topic was and that is the
supreme court
on monday the senate judiciary committee
is scheduled to open hearings on amy
coney barrett's nomination to the
supreme court senator harris
you'll be there as a member of the
committee her confirmation would
cement the court's conservative majority
and make it
likely open to more abortion
restrictions even to overturning the
landmark roe v wade ruling
access to abortion would then be up to
the states
vice president pence you're the former
governor of indiana
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
indiana to do would you want your home
state to ban
all abortions you have two minutes
uninterrupted
well thank you for the question but i'll
use a little bit of my time to respond
to that very important issue before the
american people deserve to know
qasim salamani the iranian general was
responsible for the death of
hundreds of american service members
when the opportunity came we saw him
headed to baghdad to
kill more americans president trump
didn't hesitate
and qasim salamani is gone but you
deserve to know that joe biden
and kamala harris actually criticized
the decision to take out solemn
qasim salamani it's really inexplicable
but with regard to joe biden it's it's
explainable
because history records that joe biden
actually opposed the raid against osama
bin laden
it's absolutely essential that we have a
commander-in-chief
who will not hesitate to act to protect
american lives
and to protect american service members
and that's what you have in president
donald trump
now with regard to the supreme court of
the united states let me say president
trump and i could not be more
enthusiastic
about the opportunity to see judge amy
coney barrett become justice amy coney
barrett
she's a brilliant woman and she will
bring a lifetime of experience and
a sizable american family to the supreme
court of the united states
and our hope is in the hearing next week
unlike justice kavanaugh received with
treatment from you and others
we hope she gets a fair hearing and we
particularly hope that we don't see the
kind of attacks
on her christian faith that we saw
before
i mean the democrat chairman of the
judiciary committee before
when when judge barrett was being
confirmed for the court of appeals
expressed concern that the
dogma of her faith lived loudly in her
dick durbin of illinois said that it was
a concern
senator i know one of our judicial
nominees you actually
attacked because they remember the
catholic knights of columbus
just because the knights of columbus
holds pro-life views
thank you thank you thank you vice
president when the hearing takes place
thank you vice president pence that
judge amy coney barrett will be
respected thank you vice president
voted and confirmed to the supreme court
of the united states senator harris
you're the senator from and former
attorney general of california so let me
ask you a parallel question to the one i
posed to the vice president
if roe v wade is overturned what would
you want
california to do would you want your
home state to enact no restrictions
on access to abortion and you have two
minutes
uninterrupted thank you susan first of
all
joe biden and i are both people of faith
and it's insulting to suggest that we
would
knock anyone for their faith and in fact
joe
if elected will be only the second
practicing catholic as president of the
united states
um on the issue of this of this
nomination
joe and i are very clear as are the
majority of the american people
we are 27 days before the decision about
who will
be the next president of the united
states and you know before
when this conversation has come up you
know it's been about election year or
election
time we're literally in an election
over four million people have voted
people are in the process of voting
right now
and so joe has been very clear as the
american people are
let the american people fill that seat
in the white house
and then we'll fill that seat on the
united states supreme court and to your
point susan that
the issues before us couldn't be more
serious there's the issue of choice
and i will always fight for a woman's
right to make a decision about her own
body
it should be her decision and not that
of donald trump and the vice president
michael pence
but let's also look at what else is
before the the court
it's the affordable care act like
literally
in the midst of a public health pandemic
when over 210 000 people have died
and seven million people probably have
what will be in the future considered a
pre-existing condition because you
you contracted the virus donald trump is
in court right now trying to get rid of
the affordable care act
and i said it before and it bears
repeating
this means that there will be no more
protections if they win
for people with pre-existing conditions
this means
that over 20 million people will lose
your coverage
it means that if you're under the age of
26 you can't stay on your parents
coverage anymore
and here's the thing the contrast
couldn't be more clear
they're trying to get rid of the
affordable care act joe biden is saying
let's expand coverage
let's give you a choice of a public
option or private coverage
let's bring down premiums let's lower
medicare eligibility to 60.
thank you senator that's true leadership
you know you mentioned uh
earlier vice president pence that the
president was committed
to maintaining protections for people
with pre-existing conditions
um and but you do have this court case
that you are supporting your
administration supporting
that would strike down the affordable
care act the the president says
president trump says that he's going to
protect people with pre-existing
conditions but he has not explained how
he would do that
and that was one of the toughest nuts to
crack when they were passing the
affordable
care act so tell us specifically how
would your administration
protect americans with pre-existing
conditions have access to affordable
insurance
if the affordable care act is struck
down
well thank you susan but let me just say
addressing your very first question
i i couldn't be more proud to serve as
vice president to a president who stands
without apology for the sanctity of
human life
i'm pro-life i i don't apologize for it
and this is another one of those cases
where there's such a dramatic
contrast joe biden and kamala harris
support
taxpayer funding of abortion all the way
up to the moment of birth
late term abortion they want to increase
funding to planned parenthood
of america now for our part i i would
never presume how judge amy coney
barrett
would rule on the supreme court of the
united states but
will continue to stand strong for the
right to life when you speak about
the supreme court though i think the
american people really deserve an answer
senator harris
are you and joe biden going to pack the
court if judge amy coney barrett has
confirmed
i mean there have been 29 vacancies on
the supreme court during presidential
election years from george washington to
barack obama
presidents have nominated in all 29
cases
but your party is actually openly
advocating
adding seats to the supreme court which
has had nine seats for 150 years
if you don't get your way this is a
classic case of if you can't win by the
rules
you're going to change the rules now
you've refused to answer the question
joe biden has refused to answer the
question so i think the american people
would really like to know
if judge amy coney barrett is confirmed
with the supreme court of the united
states
are you and joe biden if somehow you win
this election going to
pack the supreme court to get your way
i'm so glad we went through a little
history lesson let's do that a little
more
in 1816 i'd like you to answer the
question mr vice president
speaking i'm speaking okay
in 1864 one of the
i think political heroes certainly of
the president i i assume if you
also mr vice president is abraham
lincoln
abraham lincoln was up for re-election
and it was 27 days before the election
and a seat became open on the united
states supreme court
abraham lincoln's party was in charge
not only of the white house but the
senate
but honest abe said
it's not the right thing to do the
american people
deserve to make the decision about who
will be the next president of the united
states
and then that person can select who will
serve for a lifetime
on the highest court of our land and so
joe and i
are very clear the american people are
voting
right now and it should be their
decision
about who will serve on this most
important body
for a lifetime thank you senator
harrison susan are voting right now
they'd like to know if you and joe biden
are going to
pack the supreme court if you don't get
your way in this nomination
let's talk about that you once again
gave a non-answer joe biden gave
anonymous trying to answer you
american people deserve a straight
answer and and if you haven't figured it
out yet the straight answer is they are
going to
pack the supreme court if they somehow
win this election
men and women i got to tell you people
across this country if you cherish our
supreme court
if you cherish the separation of powers
you need to reject
the biden harris ticket come november
the 3rd re-elect president donald trump
and we'll stand by that separation
powers in a nine-seat supreme court yeah
let's talk about pac and the court then
let's talk about this yeah i'm about to
so the trump pence administration
has been because i sit on the senate
judiciary committee susan as you
mentioned
and i have witnessed the appointments
for lifetime appointments to
the federal courts district courts
courts of appeal
people who are purely ideological people
who have been reviewed by
by legal professional organizations and
found to have been not competent
are substandard and do you know
that of the 50 people who
president trump appointed to the court
of appeals for lifetime appointments
not one is black this is what
they've been doing you want to talk
about packing a court let's have that
discussion
all right thank you thank you senator
let's go on and talk about
the issue of racial justice i just want
the record to reflect she never answered
the question
so i think maybe the next debate joe
biden will answer the question but i
think the american people know the
answer thank you vice president
in march briona taylor a 26 year old
emergency room technician in louisville
was shot and killed
after police officers executing a search
warrant in a narcotics investigation
broke into her apartment
the police said they identified
themselves taylor's boyfriend said he
didn't hear them do that
he used a gun registered to him to fire
a shot which wounded an officer
the officers then fired more than 20
rounds into the apartment they say they
were acting
in self-defense none of them have been
indicted
in connection with her death senator
harris
in the case of riona taylor was justice
done you have two minutes
i don't believe so and i've i've talked
with brianna's mother tamika palmer
and her family and her family deserves
justice she was a beautiful young woman
she had as her life goal to become a
nurse and she wanted to become an emt
to first learn what's going on out on
the street
so she could then become a nurse and
save lives
and her life was taken unjustifiably and
tragically and violently
and it just it brings me to
you know the eight minutes and 46
seconds that america
witnessed during which
an american man was tortured
and killed under the knee
of an armed uniformed police officer
and people around our country of
every race of every age of
every gender perfect strangers to each
other
marched shoulder to shoulder arm and arm
fighting for us to finally achieve that
ideal of equal justice under law and i
was a part of those
peaceful protests and
i believe strongly that first of all we
are never going to
condone violence but we always must
fight
for the values that we hold dear
including the fight to achieve our
ideals
and that's why joe biden and i have said
on this subject
look and i'm a former career prosecutor
i know what i'm talking about
bad cops are bad for good cops we need
reform
of our policing in america and our
criminal justice system which is why joe
and i
will immediately ban chokeholds and
carotid holes
george floyd would be live today if we
did that we will
require a national registry for police
officers who break the law
we will on the issue of criminal justice
reform
get rid of private prisons and cash bail
and we will decriminalize marijuana and
we will
we will expunge the records of those who
have been convicted
of marijuana thank you time for
leadership on a
tragic tragic issue senator harrison
honors black people in america
thank you senator harris vice president
pence let me pose the same question to
you
in the case of briona taylor was justice
done
you have two minutes uninterrupted
well our heart breaks for the loss of
anything
any innocent american life and the
family brianna taylor has our sympathies
but i i trust our justice system
a grand jury that refused the evidence
and it really is remarkable that as a
former prosecutor
you would assume that an impaneled grand
jury looking at all the evidence got it
wrong
but you're entitled to your opinion
senator
i think look and with regard to george
floyd
there's no excuse for what happened to
george floyd and justice will be served
but there's also no excuse for the
rioting and looting
that followed i mean it really is
astonishing
flora westbrook is with us here tonight
in salt lake city
just a few weeks ago i stood at what
used to be
her salon was burned to the ground
by rioters and looters and and flora is
still trying to put her life back
together
and i must tell you this this this
presumption
that you hear consistently from joe
biden and kamala harris
that uh that america is systemically
racist
and that as joe biden said that he
believes that law enforcement has an
implicit
bias against minorities
is is a great insult to the men and
women who serve in law enforcement and i
want everyone to know who puts on the
uniform of law enforcement every day
and president trump and i stand with you
it is remarkable that that when senator
tim scott
tried to pass a police reform bill
brought together a group of republicans
and democrats senator harris
you got up and walked out of the room
and then you filibustered senator
tim scott's bill on the senate floor
that would have provided new
accountability new repeat resources
but we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
improving public safety and supporting
our african-american
thank you very much for all of our
minorities under president trump's
leadership thank you very much always
stand with law enforcement and we'll do
what we've done thank you your time is
the lives of african americans
thank you very much record investments
in education and
fight for school choice for all of our
men thank you very much i'd like to
respond
senator harris i will not sit here and
be lectured by the vice president
on what it means to enforce the laws of
our country i am the only one on this
stage
who has personally prosecuted everything
from child sexual assault to homicide
i'm the only one on the stage who has
prosecuted the big banks
for taking advantage of america's
homeowners i am the only one on this
stage
who prosecuted for-profit colleges for
taking advantage of our veterans
and the reality of this is that we are
talking about an election in 27 days
where last week the president of the
united states took a debate stage in
front of 70 million americans
and refused to condemn white
supremacists
not true and not true it wasn't like he
didn't have a chance
he didn't do it and then he doubled down
and then he said when pressed stand back
stand by and
this is a part of a pattern
of donald trump's you he was
he called mexicans rapists and criminals
he instituted as his first act a muslim
ban
he on the issue of charlottesville where
people were
peacefully protesting the need for
racial justice
where a young woman was killed and on
the other side there were neo-nazis
carrying
tiki torches shouting racial epithets
anti-semitic slurs
and donald trump when asked about it
said
there were fine people on both sides
this is who we have as the president of
the united states and america you
deserve
better joe biden will be a president who
brings our country together
senator harris and and recognizes the
beauty in our diversity
and the fact that we all have so much
more in common than what separates us
vice president pence let me give you a
minute to respond thank you susan i
appreciate that very much you know i
think that's one of the things that
makes people dislike the media so much
in this country susan
is that you selectively edit just like
senator harris did
comments that president trump and i and
others on our side of the aisle
i mean senator harris conveniently
admitted after after the president made
comments about people
on either side of the debate over
monuments
he condemned the kkk neo-nazis and white
supremacists
and has done so repeatedly
you're concerned that he doesn't condemn
neo-nazis
president trump has jewish grandchildren
his daughter and son-in-law are jewish
this is a president who who respects and
cherishes
all of the american people but you talk
about having personally prosecuted i'm
glad you brought up your record senator
thank you
but that's i really need to make this
point when you were
when you were d.a in san francisco
when you left office african americans
were 19 times
more likely to be prosecuted for minor
drug offenses than whites and hispanics
when you were attorney general of
california you increased
the the disproportionate incarceration
of
blacks in california you did nothing on
criminal justice reform in california
you didn't lift a finger to pass the
first step back on capitol hill
i mean the reality is your record speaks
for itself
president trump and i have fought for
criminal justice for
thank you vice president fought for
educational choice and opportunities for
african-americans
all of our members thank you sir and
we'll do it for four thank you you know
there is no more
important issue than the final issue
that we're going to talk about tonight
and that is the issue
of the election but itself he attacked
my record i would like an opportunity to
respond let me give you 30 seconds
because we
because we're running out of time i
appreciate that
first of all having served as the
attorney general of the state of
california
the work that i did is a model of what
our nation needs to do
and we will be able to do under a joe
biden presidency
our our agenda includes what this
administration has failed to do
it will be about not only instituting a
ban
on chocolates and carotid holes thank
you not only thank you senator i would
like to go through
these are points that you made earlier
in the hour and i want to talk about the
election itself before we have to but i
want to talk about the connection
between what joe and i will do in my
record
which includes i was the first
statewide officer to institute a
requirement that
my agents would wear body cameras and
keep them on full time
we were the first to initiate a
requirement that there would be a
training for law enforcement on implicit
bias because yes joe biden and i
recognize that implicit bias does exist
mr vice president
contrary to what you may believe we did
the work
of instituting reforms that were about
investing in reentry
this is the work that we have done and
the work we will do going forward and
again i will not be lectured by the vice
president
on our record of what we have done in
terms of law enforcement and keeping our
communities safe
and a commitment to reforming the
criminal justice system of america thank
you
senator harrison i'd like to oppose the
first
i'd like you to respond first to the
question on our final topic the election
itself
president trump has several times
refused to commit himself to a peaceful
transfer of power after the election
if your ticket wins and president trump
refuses to accept
a peaceful transfer of power what steps
would you and vice president biden then
take what would happen
next you have two minutes
so i'll tell you um joe and i are
i think particularly um proud of
the coalition that we've built around
our campaign we probably have one of the
broadest coalitions of folks that you've
ever seen in a presidential race of
course we have the support of democrats
but also
independents and republicans in fact
seven members of
president george w bush's cabinet are
supporting our ticket
we have the support of of colin powell
cindy mccain john kasich um
over 500 generals retired generals and
and former national security experts and
advisors are supporting our campaign
and i believe they are doing that
because they know that joe biden
has a deep deep-seated commitment to
fight for our democracy
and to fight for the integrity of our
democracy and to bring integrity back to
the white house
and so we believe in the american people
we believe in our democracy
and here's what i'd like to say to
everybody vote
please vote vote early come up with a
plan to vote go to iwillvote.com you can
also go to
joebiden.com we have it within our power
in these next 27 days
to make the decision about what will be
the course of our country for the next
four years
and it is within our power and if we use
our vote
and we use our voice we will win
and we will not let anyone subvert our
democracy
with what donald trump has been doing as
he did on the debate stage last week
when again in front of 70 million people
he openly attempted to suppress
the vote joe biden on the other hand on
that same debate stage because clearly
donald trump doesn't think he can run on
a record because it's a failed record
joe biden on that stage said hey just
please vote
so i'll repeat what joe said please vote
thank you
senator vice president pence president
trump has several times refused to
commit himself
to a peaceful transfer of power after
the election
if vice president biden has declared the
winner and president trump refuses to
accept a peaceful transfer of power
what would be your role and
responsibility as vice president what
would you
personally do you have two minutes
well susan first and foremost i think
we're going to win this election
because while joe biden and kamala
harris rattle off a long litany of
the establishment in washington d.c an
establishment that joe biden's been a
part of for 47 years
president donald trump has has launched
a movement of everyday americans from
every walk of life
and uh i have every confidence that
those the same americans that delivered
that historic victory in 2016
they see this president's record where
we rebuild our military
we revived our economy through tax cuts
and rolling back regulation
fighting for fair trade unleashing
american energy
we appointed conservatives to our
federal courts at every level
and and we stood with the men and women
of law enforcement every single day and
i think
i think that movement of americans has
only grown stronger in the last four
years
but when you talk about accepting the
outcome of the election
um i i must tell you senator
your party has spent the last three and
a half years trying to overturn the
results of the last election
it's amazing when joe biden was vice
president of the united states
the fbi actually spied on president
trump and my campaign
i mean there were documents released
this week that the cia actually made a
referral
uh to the fbi documenting that those
allegations were coming from the hillary
clinton campaign and of course
we've all seen the avalanche the what
what you put the country through
for for the better part of of three
years until it was found that there was
no obstruction no collusion
case closed and then senator harris you
and your colleagues in the
in the congress tried to impeach the
president of the united states
over a phone call and now hillary
clinton has actually said to joe biden
that under in her words under no
circumstances should he concede the
election
so let me just say i think we're going
to win this election
president trump and i are fighting every
day in courthouses to prevent
joe biden and kamala harris from
changing the rules and creating this
universal mail-in voting that will
create a massive opportunity for voter
fraud
and we have a free and fair election uh
we know we're going to have confidence
in it
and i believe in all my heart that
president donald trump's going to be
reelected for four more years
you know i've uh i've asked i've written
all the questions that i've asked
tonight but for the final question of
the debate
i'd like to write a read a question that
someone else wrote
the utah debate commission asked
students in the state
to write essays about what they would
like to ask you
and i want to close tonight's debate
with the question posed by brooklyn
brown
she's an eighth grader at springville
junior high in springville utah and
here's what she wrote quote
when i watch the news all i see is
arguing between democrats and
republicans when i watch the news
all i see is citizen fighting against
citizen
when i watch the news all i see are two
candidates from opposing parties
trying to tear each other down if our
leaders can't get along
how are the citizens supposed to get
along and then she added
your examples could make all the
difference
to bring us together end quote so to
each of you in turn i'd like you to take
one minute
and respond to brooklyn vice president
pence you have one minute
brooklyn it's a wonderful question and
um
let me just commend you for taking an
interest in in public life
i i started uh following the news when i
was very young
and in america we believe in a free and
open exchange of debate
and we celebrate that and it's how we've
created
literally the freest and most prosperous
nation
in the history of the world i i i would
tell you that
don't assume that what you're seeing on
your local
news networks is synonymous with the
american people
you know i look at the relationship
between justice ruth bader ginsburg the
late justice who we just lost from the
supreme court
and the late justice antonin scalia they
were on
polar opposites on the supreme court of
the united states one very
liberal one very conservative but what's
been learned since her passing was the
two of them
and their families were the very closest
of friends
i mean here in america we can disagree
we can debate vigorously as senator
harris and i have
on this stage tonight but when the
debate is over
we come together as americans and that's
what people do in big cities and small
towns all across this country so
i just want to encourage you brooklyn i
want to tell you that
we're going to work every day to have
government as good as our people
and the american people each and every
day
love a good debate we love a good
argument but we always come together and
are always there for one another
thank you times of need and we've
especially learned that
thank you for the difficulties of this
year
senator harris what would you say to
brooklyn
um first of all i i love hearing from
our young leaders
and when i hear her words when i hear
your words brooklyn
um i know our future is bright because
it is that perspective on who we are and
who we should be
um that is a sign of leadership and is
something we should all aspire to be
and that you know that brings me to joe
joe biden
one of the reasons that joe decided to
run for president
is after charlottesville which we talked
about earlier
it so troubled him and upset him like it
did all of us
that there was that kind of hate and
division
what propelled joe to run for president
was to see that over the course of the
last four years
what brooklyn described has been
happening joe has a long-standing
reputation of working across the aisle
and working in a bipartisan way and
that's what he's going to do as
president
joe biden has a history of
lifting people up and fighting for their
dignity
you mean you have to know joe's story to
know that joe has known pain
he has known suffering and he has known
love
and so brooklyn when you think about the
future
i do believe the future is bright and it
will be because of your leadership
and it will be because we fight for each
person's voice
through their vote and we get engaged in
this election because
you have the ability through your work
and through
eventually your vote thank you to
determine the future of our country
and what its leadership looks like thank
you
senator harris thank you vice president
pence thank you so much for being with
us tonight
we want to thank also the university of
utah for its hospitality
and most of all our thanks to all the
americans
who watch this debate tonight again our
best wishes for a quick recovery to
president trump
the first lady and everyone who is
battling covet 19.
the second presidential debate is next
week on october 15th
a town hall style debate in miami we
hope you'll join us then
good evening